Apple has an advertising style that's as
iconic as it is copied the internet is
full of parodies and look-alikes from
competitors yet somehow the magic in
Apple's commercials isn't spoiled even
though we know the formula it never
ceases to blow our minds to see the
newest iPhone commercial come out why
what makes Apple special a big reason is
thanks to the guidance of Mike Markkula
he was an early investor in Apple and
with the vice-president of marketing in
1977 when Apple was first getting off
the ground
Marco Lee wrote a three-point marketing
philosophy that had run into the
forefront of the company ever since
Apple's marketing focus he says should
be empathy focus and impute with empathy
Apple strives to connect customers
feelings while others talk about
detailed specs and processor power Apple
talks a lot about battery lives the way
it feels in your hands and the way it
will connect you with others focus focus
on accomplishing the main goals and
eliminate unimportant opportunities
while other companies make a million
different variations of their products
Apple only makes a few when Steve Jobs
came back to Apple he cut down their
number of product lines from several
dozen to four by refocusing Apple on a
few products they were able to create a
superior experience
impute this is possibly the most
important principle of marquales
marketing manifesto Marshall wrote
people do judge a book by its cover you
may have the best products but if you
present them poorly it will be perceived
for you if you present them in a
creative professional manner you will
impute the desired qualities in other
words the way an iPhone ad is presented
is the way that the iPhone will be
perceived and that seems obvious but
this means that even the colors of the
ad whether the space is cluttered or
clean the tone of voice of the narrator
the animations control the way the
iPhone is viewed even though all of
these have nothing to do with
smartphones actual performance and this
can either hurt or help a company which
is why I Markel of nature Apple kept it
as a guiding principle to their business
fast-forward 40 years later Apple is the
master at using this to their advantage
if you watch an Apple ad you can find
everything you need to know from the
first few seconds even if the audio is
muted now that we know the three
philosophies Apple uses
let's talk about the types of
advertisements Apple does in the
lifecycle of one of their products they
pretty much fall into three categories
the introduction this is the first video
and it's basically a hype video pumped
up music pretty screens everywhere
basically just showing off the phone
iPhone 7 make the things you do most
even better it's the best iPhone we've
ever made
[Music]
respects this is the second video
they'll make if they can get Johnny I to
do this one that's the best the point of
this video is to make people feel like
their old device is outdated and slow a
ton of talk about redesign and a lot a
lot of comparative words and they'll
also use pretty sounding but ultimately
meaningless words like color gamut
advanced sensors and unique to put it on
a much larger scale we design it's 78
percent most screen area a greater level
of precision we completely re-engineered
the touch subsystem increasing the
sensitivity of the sensors doubling the
touch refresh rate the most the highest
a greater s specifically designed a much
larger display and see more precise
multi-touch technology in entirely new
for speaker architecture more and in
different ways flexibility we've
developed a new technology more
productive more creative an entirely new
scale
after the intro inspects it's all about
narrative this is just classic content
marketing and what is that basically
it's when you tell a story where your
product just so happens to facilitate or
cause something to happen but there's no
explicit promotion pay attention to this
video because it's a classic case of
content marketing thousand times good
night
oh you're watching your daughter at a
Romeo and Juliet play and capturing that
special moment well catch it better with
the new iPhone this is a really good way
to sell anything
this fave continues to the rest of the
product life cycles until they announce
the next device at which point we come
to distances which really isn't an ad
but its necessary for advertising this
is where they wipe all the evidence of
the old advertisements from their
channels and their web page this is so
customers don't get distracted one way
if they want to buy a refurbished iPhone
5 then you have to be seven is out and
this is also so you never realized isn't
saying the same stuff for years that's
pretty much it now you know how Apple
advertises thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]